[Music]
welcome back to the BBS this money we're
all very good we all made it back safely
yes balloon die cv wasn't in the nude
welcome back to CBS this morning we're
glad you're with us more than 50 million
Americans in the path of the latest
stormy weather after heavy snow and
freezing rain slammed parts of the
country for days over the holiday
weekend winter storm alerts stretched
across 15 States this morning some parts
of the Northeast will see more than two
feet of snow today yikes
at least six deaths are blamed on this
weather and more than 60,000 people
across five states are without power
this morning the storms are making
travel brutal for more than 55 million
people returning home after Thanksgiving
Don Dahler is in the path of these
storms in Greenfield Massachusetts Don
how much snow do you see and how are the
road conditions more importantly yeah
that's the big story is it good morning
well this is lovely it looks lovely an
actually Greenfield is a really cute
town but this stuff this is trouble it's
snowed here all night long there's
probably about 10 to 12 inches on the
ground already and there's more to come
an army of snow plows have fanned out
across Massachusetts about 2400 out of
them not just to try to clear these
roads and make them safe for commuters
but also for all those people who are
desperately trying to get home after the
Thanksgiving holiday epic epic amounts
of snow historic snowfall very eyes
sliding around everywhere whiteout
conditions this is extraordinary and
sheets of ice and rain on roadways
you can tell it's winter are hammering
the country coast to coast because major
highways are now reopened in Wyoming in
Colorado after blizzard conditions shut
them down but it wasn't just the snow
storms in Arizona caused flash floods
that killed two children after the
vehicle they were in was swept away the
search continues for a missing
six-year-old girl meanwhile 50 miles
southwest we all were like scared to
death at least three tornadoes ripped
through Phoenix pulling massive trees
from the ground tarring roofs off
buildings and causing thousands to lose
power
it's crazy heavy snow Wow as the storm
barrels northeast New York police
responded to more than 550 crashes
across the state the speed limit has
been reduced to 45 miles per hour on
several highways heavy snow is burying
areas of state in Albany more than a
hundred and eighty plows are out
clearing interstates this weather is
insane
drivers in parts of Massachusetts
overnight already faced the impacts of
the more than 1 foot of snow expected
get ready you got to get to and then
stay home stay in and stay safe and
actually state officials are begging
people to do just that just stay home
today hey it's Cyber Monday do your
shopping in the comfort of your own home
if you do have to get out they say
please keep a wide berth from those snow
plows let them do their job by the way
in neighboring New York they've actually
called out the National Guard to be on
standby
they have 1500 plows in that state
working around the clock
Tony yeah it looks lovely as long as you
don't have to drive in at dawn thank you
very much